>>> NEWLY OBTAINED VIDEO TO CNN
SHOWS A FORMER GEORGIA
REPUBLICAN COUNTY OFFICIAL
ESCORTING TWO OPERATIVES HIRED
BY AN ATTORNEY FOR FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP INTO THE
COUNTY'S ELECTION OFFICES ON THE
SAME DAY A VOTING SYSTEM THERE
WAS ILLEGALLY BREACHED.
DREW GRIFFIN HAS THE DETAILS.
DREW?
>> BREACHES ARE THESE VOTING
MACHINES, GUYS AND SWING STATES
ARE UNDER INVESTIGATION ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THIS ONE HAPPENED IN COFFEE
COUNTY, GEORGIA, RURAL COUNTY.
CNN OBTAINED SURVEILLANCE VIDEO
AT ONE OF THE OFFICES WHERE THE
VOTING MACHINES WERE BREACHED
AND ALL THIS -- ONE OF DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS.
THIS IS CKATHY LATHAM WE'RE
SHOWING YOU, THE FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COFFEE COUNTY GOP.
ALREADY UNDER INVESTIGATION,
THIS WOMAN IS, FOR POSING AS ONE
OF THE FAKE ELECTORS WHO SIGNED
DOCUMENTS WHO DECLARED DONALD
TRUMP WAS THE WINNER OF THE 2020
ELECTION.
LATHAM CAN BE SEEN ESCORTING A
TEAM OF PRO TRUMP OPERATIVES
INTO THE OFFICE, INCLUDING AN IT
SPECIALIST WORKING WITH SYDNEY
POWELL.
THIS ALL HAPPENS ON THE SAME DAY
THE VOTING SYSTEM IN THAT OFFICE
WAS ILLEGALLY BREACHED.
JANUARY 7th, 2021, THE DAY AFTER
THE ATTACK ON THE U.S. CAPITOL.
TEXT MESSAGES, EMAILS, AND
WITNESS TESTIMONY FROM A CIVIL
LAWSUIT AGAINST GEORGIA ELECTION
OFFICIALS HAVE CONNECTED LATHAM,
THAT WOMAN, TO THE PLAN TO GIVE
THE GROUP ACCESS TO THE
ELECTIONS OFFICE.
ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE THIS VOTING
MACHINE BREACH, THAT SAME WOMAN
LATHAM TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
GEORGIA STATE LEGISLATURE ALONG
WITH RUDY GIULIANI, TALKING ALL
ABOUT VOTER MACHINE
IRREGULARITIES IN COFFEE COUNTY.
LATHAM'S ATTORNEY TOLD CNN IN A
STATEMENT THAT MISS LATHAM HAS
NOT ACTED IMPROPERLY OR
ILLEGALLY, AND MISS LATHAM DID
NOT AUTHORIZE OR PARTICIPATE IN
BALLOT SCANNING EFFORTS,
COMPUTER IMAGING, OR ANY SIMILAR
ACTIVITY.
THE IT SPECIALIST FIRM SAYS IT
HAD NO REASON TO BELIEVE HE WAS
DOING ANYTHING WRONG EITHER.
ONE IMPORTANT NOTE, COFFEE
COUNTY, WHERE THIS HAPPENED, IS
A REPUBLICAN STRONGHOLD.
DONALD TRUMP WON THIS COUNTY
WITH 70% OF THE VOTE, BUT YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE VIDEO THERE
THAT THE TRUMP CONNECTED TEAM
WANTED TO AND WAS ABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO THAT ELECTION IS
OFFICE.
>> AS YOU SAID, DREW, THIS ISN'T
THE ONLY PLACE THIS KIND OF
THING IS HAPPENING.
>> NO.
THERE WERE -- THIS WAS
HAPPENING, BREACHES OF VOTING
MACHINES, IN SEVERAL OTHER
STATES AND AT LEAST ONE OF THE
BREACHES, BRIANNA, IN MICHIGAN,
WE CAN CONNECT TO WHAT HAPPENED
IN GEORGIA.
IT ALL POINTS TO THIS PLAN TO
TRY TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS OF
THE 2020 ELECTION.
BUT LOOK AT ALL THE THINGS THEY
HAVE DONE, ALL THE DIGGING THEY
HAVE DONE, ALL THE VOTING
MACHINES THEY HAVE TRIED TO
PENETRATE, NONE OF IT HAS SHOWN
ANY OF THIS EVIDENCE THAT THEY
THINK EXISTS OUT THERE, YOU KNOW
THAT THIS WAS SOMEWHAT OF AN
ILLEGITIMATE ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN WON THIS ELECTION AND
THEY JUST COULD NOT ACCEPT THAT.
>> SO, DREW, WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE INVESTIGATION INTO ALL
OF THIS?
>> WELL, THERE ARE VARIOUS STATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THE MICHIGAN SECRETARY OF STATE
TOLD ME LAST WEEK THAT SHE
HANDED OVER HER STATE'S EVIDENCE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY HAVE NOT HEARD BACK.
IT IS AN INCREDIBLE INTRICATE
STORY.
YOU KNOW, ZATKO AND JASON
MORRIS, TWO CRACK INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
JUST POSTED A BIG STORY ONLINE
WITH MORE DETAILS ON THIS,
INCREDIBLE STUFF, IF YOU WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG OR, GUYS, READ
ABOUT IT IN THE HISTORY BOOKS
IN, LIKE, TEN YEARS FROM NOW.
>> YEAH, FOLLOW ALONG NOW,
YOU'LL BE WELL PREPARED FOR WHEN
YOU READ IT IN THE HISTORY
BOOKS.
DREW GRIFFIN, TERRIFIC
REPORTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME NOW, CNN
POLITICAL ANALYST AND SENIOR
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT TO "THE
NEW YORK TIMES" MAGGIE HABERMAN
AND CNN LEGAL ANALYST AND FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR JENNIFER
ROGERS.
THERE IS A LOT IN THERE, IN
DREW'S REPORT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT JANUARY 7th,
THE DAY AFTER THE INSURRECTION.
THIS IS STILL GOING ON EVEN
AFTER EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6th.
>> IT FITS WITH OTHER PIECES WE
KNOW, JOHN, WHICH IS THAT JOHN
EASTMAN, THE LAWYER, WHO WAS THE
ARCHITECT OF THIS IDEA THAT MIKE
PENCE COULD UNILATERALLY REJECT
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTES ON
JANUARY 6th CONTINUED PRESSING
IN GEORGIA ACTUALLY.
HE WANTED TO CONTINUE
INVESTIGATING IN GEORGIA.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THERE ARE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO SHARED HIS
VIEWS, WHO WERE CONTINUING, BUT
THE DETAIL OF THIS IS REALLY
WHAT IS STUNNING.
I HAVE TO SAY, THIS IS ONE OF
THE FIRST TIMES THAT I THINK
THERE HAS BEEN A CLEAR ROAD MAP
PRESENTED IN ONE OF THESE
STORIES ABOUT MACHINES BEING
EITHER A BREACH OR SOMETHING
TAMPERED WITH POTENTIALLY, WHERE
YOU CAN CONNECT THE DOTS BETWEEN
PLAYERS ACROSS THE SPECTRUM IN
THIS ENTIRE ISSUE AND IT IS A
FASCINATING REPORT.
>> IT IS.
I HAVE TO SAY, MORE TO COME, I'M
SURE.
JEN, I WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
RULING FROM JUDGE AILEEN CANNON
IN FLORIDA, THE DISTRICT JUDGE,
SAYING THERE WILL BE A SPECIAL
MASTER DEALING WITH THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE SEIZED AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
AND THERE WILL BE A PAUSE IN
INVESTIGATORS' ABILITY TO LOOK
AT THESE AND USE THESE DOCUMENTS
IN THE INVESTIGATION.
I THINK TWO MAJOR QUESTIONS AND
HOPEFULLY WE'LL COVER BOTH.
NUMBER ONE, THE RULING ITSELF,
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF IT, AND
SECONDLY, WE'LL GET INTO THIS,
WHAT HAPPENS NOW.
FIRST, THE RULING.
>> IT IS A MESS.
IT REALLY IS A MESS.
THE JUDGE HAD TO FIND TO
ESTABLISH JURISDICTION AND
APPOINT THE SPECIAL MASTER AND
JOIN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FROM
USING THE DOCUMENTS, A WHOLE
BUNCH OF CRITERIA THAT ARE
DELINEATED AND STATUTES AN
CASES, RIGHT?
FOR EACH OF THOSE SHE EITHER
IGNORES THEM ALTOGETHER OR
PROVIDES REALLY UNPERSUASIVE
EVIDENCE OF THESE ELEMENTS.
JUST TO GIVE ONE EXAMPLE,
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, IN ORDER TO
SAY THE SPECIAL MASTER CAN
REVIEW EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, SHE
HAS TO SHOW -- OR DONALD TRUMP
AS A MOVEMENT HAS TO SHOW AND
SHE HAS TO FIND IRREPARABLE HARM
AND LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS ON THE
MERITS.
SHE CAN NOT DO THAT.
SHE DOESN'T EVEN DO THE LEGAL
ANALYSIS WITH RESPECT TO
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
ALL SHE SAYS IS IT IS NOT 100%
PRECLUDED BY THE SUPREME COURT
THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE AN
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE HERE.
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF SPACE IN
BETWEEN NOT 100% AND LIKELIHOOD
OF SUCCESS ON THE MERITS, WHICH
IS 51%, RIGHT?
SO TIME AND TIME AGAIN, JUDGE
CANNON REALLY JUST DOESN'T DO
ANY PERSUASIVE LEGAL ANALYSIS
HERE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS, MAGGIE,
YOU POINT OUT, MERRICK GARLAND
HAS ALWAYS SAID THAT THE DOJ IS
GOING TO PURSUE ITS
INVESTIGATIONS WITHOUT FEAR OR
FAVOR.
THIS JUDGE, IN HER RULING,
ALMOST SEEMED TO SAY IN THIS
CASE, THERE IS SOME FAVOR THAT
DONALD TRUMP AS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT MIGHT BE IN A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
>> THIS JUDGE WHO TRUMP
APPOINTED CARVED OUT WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY A TRUMP EXCEPTION OR
PRESIDENTIAL EXCEPTION, I GUESS
I SHOULD SAY.
SHE BASICALLY TALKS ON AND ON
ABOUT HOW -- NOT BASICALLY, SHE
DOES TALK ON AND ON ABOUT HOW
DISDAIN OF AN INVESTIGATION CAN
LEAVE, YOU KNOW, AN IRREPARABLE
MARK ON HOW DAMAGING THAT CAN
BE, SHE IGNORES THE FACT THAT
THE SEARCH WARRANT THAT EXISTED,
ANOTHER MAGISTRATE SIGNED OFF
ON, APPROVED OF, BECAUSE HE
FOUND OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE OF
PROBABLE CAUSE, THAT THERE WERE
POTENTIAL CRIMES BEING
COMMITTED.
AND THIS WAS AFTER A YEAR AND A
HALF OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO GET BACK DOCUMENTS
THAT BELONGED TO THE GOVERNMENT,
NOT TO DONALD TRUMP.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW ANY OF THAT,
REALLY, FROM LOOKING AT THIS
RULING.
AND SO IT IS STRIKING HOW THIS
JUDGE HAS CREATED THIS
EXCEPTION, SUGGESTING THAT TRUMP
SHOULD BE GIVEN MORE DEFERENCE
THAN REALLY ANY OTHER, YOU KNOW,
PERSON WHO IS FACING AN
INVESTIGATION GETS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> SO, WHAT NOW?
IF YOU WERE THERE, IF YOU WERE
ONE OF THESE PROSECUTORS, WOULD
YOU APPEAL KNOWING THAT THE
APPEAL MIGHT DELAY EVEN MORE?
>> THIS IS A TOUGH QUESTION
BECAUSE THEY REALLY HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT TWO THINGSI STHINGS.
WHAT DAMAGE IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TO THEIR INVESTIGATION, AS A
RESULT OF THE INJUNCTION OF THIS
BEING ISSUED AND ON THAT SCORE,
I THINK THEY MIGHT APPEAL
BECAUSE THE JUDGE DIDN'T JUST
SAY PUT THE DOCUMENTS ASIDE.
SHE SAYS YOU CAN'T USE THEM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
THEY HAVE REVIEWED ALL OF THESE
DOCUMENTS.
SO THEY HAVE FOUND LEADS FOR
WITNESS INTERVIEWS.
THEY MAY BE ISSUING NEW
SUBPOENAS.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
CAN THEY NOT ISSUE SUBPOENAS, IF
THE SUBPOENAS WERE ISSUED, CAN
THEY NOT LOOK AT THE RETURNS
WHEN THEY COME IN?
WE DON'T KNOW THE SPECIAL MASTER
WON'T KNOW.
THEY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT DO THEY
NEED TO APPEAL IN ORDER TO GET
THIS INJUNCTION OVERTURNED OR
CLARIFIED AND THEN THE OTHER
ISSUE IS, DOES THIS SET A BAD
PRECEDENT FOR GOING FORWARD?
WILL DOJ HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE SUBJECT TO
SEARCHES COMING IN AND SAYING,
WELL, I KNOW I HAVEN'T BEEN
CHARGED YET, BUT A WANT A
SPECIAL MASTER TOO, WHAT ABOUT
ME?
I THINK THE PRECEDENT ISN'T TOO
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE SHE MAKES
SUCH A BIG DEAL OF THE
EXCEPTIONAL NATURE OF THIS.
HE'S THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THIS IS ABOUT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IN LARGE PART.
SO ON THOSE SCORES I THINK IT
DOESN'T REALLY APPLY NECESSARILY
TO OTHER POTENTIAL SEARCH
WARRANT FOLKS DOWN THE ROAD.
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE TWO
COMPETING ISSUES.
>> MAGGIE, WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING
GOING FORWARD NOW?
>> THE APPEAL IS OBVIOUSLY THE
MAIN THING.
HOW LONG DOES THIS TAKE, JOHN?
LET'S SAY THE DOJ GOES AHEAD
WITH THE APPEAL, HOW LONG DOES
THIS STOP THEIR INVESTIGATION
EVEN AS THAT'S PLAYING OUT.
DOES THIS KICK INTO NEXT YEAR,
INTO 2023, WHICH IS VERY
POSSIBLE AND I KNOW ONE THING WE
DIDN'T DISCUSS IS HOW DO THE TWO
SIDES EVEN AGREE ON WHO IS
SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING TO BE
WHO HAS THE SECURITY CLEARANCES
FOR THIS.
IT IS A WILD DECISION.
>> THE JUDGE DID SAY, YOU GET
TOGETHER, FIGURE OUT WHO THE
SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING TO BE
AND COME BACK TO ME.
HARD TO IMAGINE.
>> THEY HAD SO MUCH AGREEMENT SO
FAR, I'M SURE THIS WILL GO
SWIMMINGLY.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THIS MORNING.